un momento reservado para la economía en
france 24 para ello me acompaña luis
méndez duris louis bienvenido iniciamos
en eeuu porque hay buenas noticias para
la economía del país norteamericano
acidez marina y es que de acuerdo con la
oficina de estadísticas laborales el
desempleo en la nación cayó a la cifra
más baja desde que se inició la pandemia
la tasa en el mes de julio se ubicó en
5,4 por ciento es decir 87 millones de
personas se encuentran desocupadas en la
unión americana 782.000 menos que el
número registrado en el mes de junio del
presente año precisamente en el séptimo
mes de este año se crearon 943 mil
nuevos empleos un crecimiento de cinco
mil puestos si lo comparamos con junio
del mismo año los datos se presentan un
día después de dar a conocer que durante
la semana pasada 385 mil personas
solicitaron ayudas por desempleo
llevando la media en cuatro semanas a
394.000 solicitudes escuchemos lo que
dijo el presidente estadounidense al
respecto
lo que es indiscutible ahora es esto el
plan de vaivén está funcionando el plan
de vaivén está generando resultados y el
plan de bailén está haciendo avanzar al
país somos ahora la primera
administración en la historia en sumar
empleos cada mes en los primeros seis
meses en el cargo y la primera en la
historia en sumar más de cuatro millones
de trabajos en sus primeros seis meses
first six mans vamos ahora al sur del
continente en argentina el presidente
del país alberto fernández estima un
crecimiento de la economía para este año
y el próximo
así es marina y es que el jefe de estado
argentino considera necesario abrir una
serie de sectores ligados a la industria
para continuar con este crecimiento
además prevé la aplicación de medidas
que fortalezcan al sector turístico del
país
fernández sustento el proceso de
recuperación económica en la vacunación
con lo cual se estarían generando
puestos de empleo y además también
sustentó con las inversiones en el país
en este sentido el jefe de la casa
rosada- estimó un crecimiento de 7 por
ciento para este año y de 4,5 por ciento
para el 2022 escuchemos
estamos en pleno camino de recuperación
económica
la argentina crece y recupera empleos y
va a recuperar ingresos
para que llegue a todos ese crecimiento
lograremos incorporar más sectores a la
reactivación
en argentina este año
va a crecer alrededor del 7 por ciento y
el año entrante calculamos que va a
crecer alrededor del 4,5 por ciento
hoy mismo estamos generando miles de
puestos de trabajo vamos a hablar ahora
de la empresa de tecnología huawei que
presentó su balance de semestral de
acuerdo con un informe la empresa
registró una reducción en sus ingresos
de 29% en comparación con los primeros
seis meses del año 2020 de acuerdo con
la organización los ingresos estuvieron
por el orden de los 49 mil 600 millones
de dólares una reducción en comparación
con los 70 mil 200 millones de dólares
que se registró en la primera mitad del
año 2020 esta empresa de acuerdo con sus
directivos se vio afectada en parte por
las sanciones impuestas en 2019 por la
entonces presidencia de donald trump que
entre otras cosas le impide acceder a
tecnología de origen que estadounidense
y crece la preocupación en los países
asiáticos ante una posible
desaceleración de la economía china es
una situación que se desprende de un
informe del diario hongkonés south china
morning post' y que se presenta debido
al aumento en el intercambio comercial
de estos países y otros de asia con
china en los últimos años los temores se
sustentan luego de que china presenta
zoom
gestores de compra conocido como pm y en
el mes de julio de 54 una reducción en
comparación con el mes de junio que fue
de 59 además durante el último año el
bloque de países del sudeste asiático se
convirtió como el de mayor intercambio
comercial con china al presentar un
volumen de 733 mil seiscientos mil
millones de dólares de acuerdo con el
informe el temor de las economías
asiáticas a una desaceleración china es
que pueda traer una caída de las
principales monedas y corea del sur
sería uno de los países más afectados y
cuál es la cifra del día de la cifra del
día tiene que ver en este caso con los
32 mil litros de cerveza con alcohol que
se produjeron dentro de la unión europea
durante el año 2020 una cifra que
traemos el día de hoy como parte del día
internacional de las empresas bueno
bueno pues muchas cervezas de bebió en
la unión europea aunque al parecer menos
que el año pasado en 2007
graciasluis por la información económica
y a ustedes gracias sigan con más en
france 24 punto com
[Música]